by the way I will mention that JD is now
addicted to weed he smoked weed again
last night
what yeah he might be a pothead now from
what I understand there was a bunch of
things going on so first thing that
happened was Ronnie his journey on pot
did not end when the radio show ended
yes right so I journey journey is a good
word
Ronnie is [ __ ] wild I've never I've
smoked a lot with people
he's never clean [ __ ] I've never
seen anything like he claims to not
remember what happened yesterday now and
what to hit or the pots really strong on
you every time I look at him we were
both start do you think you were highly
yeah I couldn't tell exactly but you
look like you were I felt different
I felt like my blood moving slower
something was moving slower inside my
you know my head was lightheaded Ronnie
I heard you were bummed out afterwards
what happened was like probably right
after the show ended maybe an hour
afterwards I started get this paranoia
oh yeah it wasn't like crazy Perry's
like like everybody's what like
everybody was looking at me like what an
[ __ ] pissed off at me yeah when was
this while you were still here Howard he
was accusing everybody of that oh yeah
walk by me go I know you don't like me I
know y'all don't [ __ ] like yeah man
it was like it was crazy and you were
verbalizing yeah because we're so happy
I look at people as they walk by me and
it was I would just look at their face
in their eyes and they would like turn
away and I'm I guess I was like
imagining all this yeah well paranoia
[ __ ] leave really I had to leave the
building what about Ronnie pop if did
you have to go back to your room cuz you
were pretty happy on the air I was fine
yeah what's wrong with this [ __ ] I do
want to get back to my room
I couldn't like sit still what was the
room spinning no no nothing like that
I started packing really started writing
my memoir all right if I pack now I
don't have to pack later
you know whenever I'm leaving right I'll
start packing and I started pulling [ __ ]
out of the drawers and like putting
stuff like I mean well this is might
need for tomorrow right I packed all my
my eulogy my limit spots were rotating
then I laid down right and Stephanie had
called me she was on a lunch break right
I guess I passed out for like eight
minutes all right
and then the phone rang oh I hate that
hello but it was good because I had to
get up because we were going out and
what we see with you in the lighter show
me how you light a lighter why couldn't
you get the lighter go here here's a
lighter but the [ __ ] is wrong with you
that you can't light a lighter yeah keep
sliding off let me see you really
uncoordinated holding it I like that
you're holding the might be lighter up
to the bank JP do you have like a
coordination issue you can't do that I
can't
that's what happened yesterday same
thing one try Howard one try high to
life it's not like I'm Superman yeah you
only try the end yeah what seeing that
it works yeah maybe I have asked finger
you're like a caveman see I am like a
good father to him I teach him thing Oh
mind you had it all right give me that
[Laughter]
how much weed did you smoke last night
it sounds birthday party that's a couple
hits off a able to coffee and get the
whole thing done you I felt it in my
throat right don't think I coughed too
much does it get into your lungs I mean
that's what you got it I guess I feel it
my throat I'm assuming it goes until I
was with him this time and I want know
he definitely inhaled how was that
experience I was fine I was also
drinking so I said wasn't sure I mean I
felt good Roger that anymore I felt what
happened was when I started you know we
went to the party and I started to drink
yeah it's like all came back again he
had a flashback
you know like dude the weed out here
must be strong I mean maybe I didn't
smoke any wheat Wow well I had a couple
of drinks and it was like right party
relevant party Ronnie know that was
drinking Ronnie what else yeah he was
back to accusing of saying that he
didn't like other people the way to
hates me I will always do you know
that's your routine that's personality
yep stick yeah well so Ronnie went from
happy Ronnie yes then he moved into hey
everybody here hates me right paranoid
Ronnie and then went by the time he
started drinking at night he was back to
I hate all of Ronnie angry Ron just
normal Ronnie yeah